that was part one have a look at part
two with me what do you mean us too sure
and what's going to be the quickest part
they're very good so I'm looking for
this point here right you see how
important drawing the diagram is there's
no normal going through and they call
these end because it's where the normals
gonna cost me the answers right so
therefore if I got the equation of this
line that like that
n is on right what do I need to do with
this equation in order to get the
coordinate yeah very good sir I'm going
to say n is on the x-axis right
therefore Y is equal zero
I have to say that the first thing
because by definition that's what it is
like it meets the axis x axis at the end
but that gives you the y coordinate
remember I must assure that the corner
has la blah blah 0 so there's my zero
now I need to cut that into this
equation to get out my my x coordinate
their expected okay so let's go ahead
and do that so y is 0 so I'm going to
get 0 minus y naught equals and
everything else the same
okay now one of the things that's nice
here is that having just got rid of that
a white erm you can see I can also get
rid of the why not - do you notice that
abuse is divided through nice now that
was just some simple finals obviously
what about run into it this thing like
what's them what's their chart I'm
trying trying to get towards the plot
the end good I'm trying to make X
subject that's the first thing I notice
the second thing I notice is have a look
like this issue they're really very nice
to me they're giving us a whole bunch of
show results right so you know where
you're going you don't have to simplify
that I have a look at that next corner
do you notice the x coordinate has no a
square and don't be square didn't you
notice that right
all that's got is an e square that's the
eccentricity right so number one way
obviously gonna have to do a bit of
simplifying he just expand rearrange it
cetera but not only that we're going to
have to take advantage of a relationship
that gets rid of a square to be spreads
and replaces them with an d square of
some kind now like I'll just try to get
in our heads the direction we're going
in where under the lips what is that
relationship V squared equals a squared
outside of one minus e square and we
know it why is it one minds Eastwick how
do we know it's not the other one
because it's on an ellipse the
eccentricity has to be between nor than
one right so that's why this number is
smaller we have to keep everything
positive so just keep that in your back
pocket right this is going to comment
we're gonna need this and you can know
it right away having written down this
line and knowing where you're gonna go
okay right let's carry out some of the
algebra now I guess we're going to try
to get rid of this fraction so I will
multiply through
and then while I'm at it I might as well
expand that right head side yeah
how does that look said okay now
remember you guys told me I'm trying to
make X the subject so I guess I will
love
I'll keep this guy over here and while
I'm at it it looks like I can do some
super flying as well sure it looks to me
like
okay how's that look so far I've just
done a little bit of shifting around
okay and I'm almost there I'm almost got
and equals now I don't especially
conventional factorize now but I put the
X alone at the end rather than getting
anyone to tell me why I bother doing
that have a look at where I'm going
right the excellence on the end like I
lost okay so so now I'm gonna divide
through rights on getting a squared
minus B squared all over a square okay
now this ought to make me very
suspicious
I haven't done anything dramatic with
the algebra I have a fraction here but I
am NOT expecting a fraction I expecting
this thing is just gonna come out in the
wash and be e square anymore this just Y
should do so so you look at this guy
right it'll be this guy now hey you got
a couple of choices you can do some
manipulation here over here
to make the transition a bit easier but
I kind of reckon you know what Beamen
I'm expecting if I thought about how to
arrive then this thing should come out
really nicely to wash I'm just gonna do
a straight substance you should okay so
I'm gonna go that is minus a squared 1
minus e squared is that okay
that's respectful
is that again
do you see what's happening see what's
happening you this is a squared minus a
squared band that goes right to that
doctor disappears and what you're left
with is a square d squared all divided
by a square
and there is the result reception now
some people I remember see this kind of
question the first time and I was like
ma'am
does this not this is the step here does
this not come out of the blue like how
did someone know to do that and the
thing is you guys all told me you knew
you needed to from immediately from
riding it's like how did you know what
was the clue you look at this right and
there's no two ways of getting around
them
it clearly follows from part one and
then you look at where you've got to go
you know I'm gonna get from here to here
this is the only recourse I have to get
rid of basically did miss Benson to
replace them with a t-square so
therefore no don't be surprised that
this is coming out of and this is not
coming out of pool at all actually you
don't have any other choice